I want to see you again version of Maya
I made a good purchase for autumn Wanihime-
san I wonder if Inuyama-san is like this
Yes a day I'm here in Uji Mari
Thank you Nadeshiko I'll enjoy the bonfire
Saito  If you get close to Tenichi, it's okay if a woman burns, but it's surprisingly difficult, isn't it?
Pulling
out the gentle signs that opened me,
a
wonderful
floor ana kanban
mar
kimi ni
ni
[music]
me
dan
[music]
me
ani
[music]
ni
debian
ah ah ah
[music]
oh
[music] hm ah [music]
can't you see the clouds today?
Please write your name and contact information here Please
check out at 10:00 tomorrow morning Please feel free to use the items in the forest.
I'm going to be a
racer You're a
strong girl
[Applause] Yes
hahahaha
[Music] It's a
reserved state, it's
sinking off, it's the best
Other edge 8th place
It smells good, I'm
returning home from the ride, but
the bamboo sun makes a fire, and it's troublesome to strike
out.
An excellent natural ignition agent that catches fire with
an open umbrella is dry and burns well.
Choose the ones that are as dry as possible. If they're
too wet, they won't catch fire or
crack. If you're going to buy one, I recommend Makiya's.
There is also a generous campsite called
[Music
] I picked up too much
again,
but it's
okay.
It's
thin, so I'll put it on
[Music]
Place the thicker firewood gradually while making a gap so that air can pass.
I know it's going to smell
bad, but I don't understand
this warmth  My mother,
Mr. Kuji, is wearing a hat.
Did you go home late?
I spent my time in the column that was turned off
Haa Before I knew it, it was a pillow, right?  Smartphone smartphone Smoothmon Drying off
Smartphone shoes
Gwa I'll eat the road
a Give me 1,500 yen
Yeah
yeah yeah I'm asking you to buy a para pond It's a lie Maybe
this is me 9 The
gust pot is black with soot over the bonfire  It's going to be
a
[music] It's
Thailand Hey,
what is it?
Come
to think of it, I've never been to a camp with a matching outfit. I went camping with someone
.
[music]
hmm
tee
me
dha
[music]
Oh, I'm getting tired Oh
, I got a burn in my house
Why is it going to rain
?
Hey, where did you come from?
I've been listening and I've been climbing I'm in
trouble and I can't see at all Don
[music]
Listen to many turns I
can't see or yeah
[music]
ana
Yo,
my stupid sister
really took care of me
This is a tree, no big deal o If
you don't carry it around, you can't call it a mobile
phone.
Good night,
don't
catch a cold
.
[Music]
Let's do it properly next time
Yahoo!  Sister,
did you have any
camping equipment at home?  Hey
[music]
Come on, come on, it's
okay, it feels
good
.
ni
me
love me
ahaan
kono right
[music]
kono is
n't there right now ah
ana
ano gakkotsu,
right?
I
don't like it
I want to have a lamp What do you think of us
who made Nokuru in April
?
A tent with a heater wouldn't sell.
[music]